who's this guy is this a king of the
sting thing or another podcast we're
about to watch yeah
of course with the beard bro
you guys as well i know him you do i
don't
okay i know him through answer i oh no i
did i did a show with this guy one time
i think he's a comedian what's going on
everybody my name is box of beats from
los angeles california this is my friend
loopy loopy loopy loopy loopy the way he
did that
and we want to ask you can we see when
you are stinging it beatboxing looping
version
before you answer check this out
the oh just getting some fire the
[ __ ] scent the the face he made after
the first loopy yeah the most insecure
face in the world now just one point he
said the first which was only a one week
brenden by the way
my friend loopy
loopy loopy right there oh so insecure
come on
man
be a man about it what happened he's
insecure right there you can see by his
father's looping before you make fun of
me yeah exactly but it's i'm basically
going to drop
that is brendan all right let's see what
you've got
you're having a little extra sip that's
brenda that's eggnog
i mean the lights in the back you know
fire
britain falls for any beat in the
beginning though that's he's the first
dude to [ __ ] drop like
yeah i'll go the dance floor with this
king in the stink king
video game
and brennan just stole a sandwich
and a book but he gets rid of the book
immediately for a hundred points it can
only carry certain things
this guy is very cool this guy is cool
oh he drink that's so dick to drink in
the middle oh wait what is he drinking
huh
egg whites he's having a sip of
something it's just ice honestly the
thing is
[Laughter]
that was fire it was really cool that
was good i expected it to go further did
you
no actually i thought it would do that
you guys are lying no no
a little more to it i didn't i didn't i
like the that's your that's one of his
problems though
you don't expect greatness but that's
but i'm not saying that it wasn't great
when i see a guy like that those are my
standards yeah okay no i'm not trying to
be shitty but he's i don't know who he
is he's just a guy who submitted
something usually people who submit are
not that amazing
[Music]
[Music]